[Musique]
génération identitaire voilà le nom d'un
groupuscule d'extrême droite qui depuis
des années fait beaucoup parler le 21
janvier balances ton post leur consacrer
une émission spéciale en invitant leurs
porte paroles tu as his death qu fond
pour tenter de comprendre leurs actions
la civilisation européenne
elle est aujourd'hui menacée de
disparaître par cette invasion
migratoire
ce soir-là sa venue avait fait vivement
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux dans la
foulée gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur se disaient choqués par ces
différentes opérations et souhaitait y
mettre un terme
je n'hésiterai pas pour poser la
dissolution génération identitaire
vendredi soir l'organisation a été
notifié d'une demande de dissolution
s'il n'apporte pas d'éléments nouveaux
pour leur défense la dissolution sera
donc effectif sous 15 jours alors
comprenez vous la future dissolution de
génération identitaire génération
identitaire leur principe courage
excellence humilité communauté
persévérance identité ses seins sur leur
site internet on peut retrouver ce genre
d'allégations pour tenter de rameuter
des jeunes principalement tu te
retrouves pas dans leurs discours
politique pour toi les chaînes de
télévision des beats le même baratin en
continu tu en as et que des petits prof
youtube et les gauchistes de ton lit ses
vomissures ton pays et son histoire sur
internet cinéma dans les séries télé
partout on veut te faire culpabiliser
blanc et héros pour eux tu es de trop
génération identitaire point org une
autonomie quand tu sors de chez toi tu
n'es pas en sécurité
dans le bus on soirée à l'école la
racaille peut frapper cette violence
n'existe pas sans raison c'est
l'immigration invasion en traversant
certains quartiers tu ne reconnais plus
tôt pays
l'islamisation gomme notre identité est
au fond de toi tu bout tu ne le
supportais pas car tu ne supportes pas
kebab voit les mosquées n'ont rien à
faire ici tu le sens bien c'est ta
conviction profonde inébranlable
chacun sait chez soi ça c'est des choses
sur le site de génération identitaire
point org
le racisme anti blanc est une réalité
mais pas une fatalité nous sommes des
éveilleurs de conscience génération
identitaire point org
les écrits qui choque les écrits qui
chausse de corne
êtes vous d'accord avec la dissolution
de ce groupe génération identitaire
thaïs discussion vous êtes là vous êtes
la porte parole de ce groupe puisque
vous étiez venu dans balances ton post
est ce que votre présence dans balances
ton post est ce que le sujet qu'on l'a
fait dans balances ton post a à jouer ou
bien c'était déjà mis en place avant je
ne pense pas je pense que cela fait déjà
longtemps que les différents
gouvernements on souhaitait dissoudre
génération identitaire pour des raisons
politiques notamment et ils avaient ils
n'ont pas les outils juridiques en soit
pour le faire puisque nous n'avons
aucune raison valable juridiquement
parlant d' être dissous le fait est que
gérald darmanin annoncé souhaiter
souhaité nous dissoudre la et donc
s'applique à vouloir le faire mais on a
lancé la procédure
c'est à dire que vendredi soir le
président de génération identitaire a
reçu à son domicile
la lettre qui l'informé de la mise en
place de la procédure de dissolution et
d'ailleurs en fait tous les motifs qui
étaient invoquées n'ont absolument aucun
fondement alors elles sont assez
ridicules je pourrais vous donner des
exemples nous les donnerais tu à risque
puisque forcément aussi qu'ils avaient
voulu être là ce soir c'est pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'on voulait dire à yassine
belattar a également un mode voilà qui
est la mode brégeon porte parole de la
république en marche qu'est-ce que vous
avez alors dire à la mode surtout voilà
pourquoi il faut pas dix autres
générations identitaire parce que ici
vous allez voir oui non oui non mais
t'es bien vos pancartes s'il vous plaît
les chéris qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire pourquoi vouliez venir ce soir en
direct
déjà parce que disent ou deux
générations identitaire je pense que
c'est une atteinte grave à la liberté
d'expression à la liberté d'association
et le fait est que juridiquement parlant
vous n'avez pas les outils pour deux
pour dissoudre génération identitaire si
vous le faites c'est évidemment pour des
raisons politiques et idéologiques
d'ailleurs ça rentre dans votre agenda
politique puisque d'un côté vous avez
donc vous a fait semblant de donner des
gages à la droite en 10 août dissolvant
baraka city ou le ccf qui sont des
associations islamistes qui ont pour le
coup de réels liens avérés avec le
terrorisme islamiste et donc d'un autre
côté vous voulez donner des gages à la
gauche dont vous avez besoin de cet
électorat donc en dissolvant génération
identitaire alors évidemment vous
choisissiez génération identitaire parce
que ça fait un certain moment que ce que
ce mouvement s'est quand même imposé
comme le mouvement le plus efficace le
plus organisé le plus structuré en tout
cas qu'il était capable de faire face à
enfin tous ko nous opposant politique et
que nos actions sont efficaces mais on
voulait frapper au coeur de l'identité
titleist des ce que font moi comme je
vous ai dit à la fois un mois j'ai
commencé l'interview vous disant vous
prenez pour qui vous fait parfois et
souvent des actions où vous outrepassez
vos droits
je suis désolé vous n'êtes pas regarder
ce que maintenant est ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est qu'en fait tout
simplement nous ce que nous avons
demandé au final c'est
nous respectons la loi quand nous sommes
allés au col du portillon tout ce que
nous demandions c'était que la loi soit
appliquée aux migrants clandestins qui
puisque quand même aux dernières
nouvelles franchir une frontière
illégalement pas que ça renchérit de
fontiès alex harvey a laissé importance
alors qu'en malaisie
on vous reproche pas d'avoir une opinion
vous avez le droit d'avoir une opinion
je la partage pas c'est une chose mais
vous avez le droit de la voir en
revanche l'incitation à la haine
l'incitation aux açores masqueront
l'occurrence que j'ai le mien de racisme
ça en france certes est interdit c'est
interdit donc quand vous montez sur le
toit d'une mosquée pour scander les
slogans anti mousse juillet juste mais
moins terminé mais ce fait
continuellement le lien un lien direct
des amalgames volontaire entre l'islam
les migrants et le terrorisme ça c'est
interdit ça s'appelle de l'incitation à
la haine et c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
que le gouvernement dissout génération
identitaire ou en tout cas veut
dissoudre génération identitaire vous
avez dix jours pour répondre dans le
cadre d'une procédure contradictoire
mais en fait la démarche si vous voulez
elle est la même que lorsque le
gouvernement a dissout baraka city ou le
ccf parce que dans deux genres très
différents
vous prenez la haine est en sable fait
du mal à ce qu'est la république
française et à notre capacité à faire
société ensemble mais qu'on soit bien
qu'hier d'un clair pardon on n'est pas
là non excusez-moi un délit de sale
gueule
vous vous avez une très bonne tête mais
c'est ce que vous dites qu'on peut être
qui pose problème
c'est ce que vous dites mais ce que vous
faites dans mais c'est ça la vraie
comprenez que vos actions
voilà c'est moche moi ce que j'ai lu
tout à l'heure je suis dernier à venir
des propos racistes et le racisme est un
délit en france
voilà c'est tout donc non mais je cours
je m'attendais effectivement à ce que
vous disiez ça néanmoins si vous voulez
effectivement nous dissoudre pour
incitation à la haine raciale un
discours c'est une conduite en mai si
vous voulez nous dissoudre pour
incitation à la haine raciale comme vous
le dites il faut bouger les audigier les
outils juridiques pour le faire on est
d'accord
néanmoins lorsque nous avons occupé le
chantier de la mosquée de poitiers donc
l'action dont vous parlez nous n'avons
eu aucune condamnation
nous n'avons pas été condamné la
violation d'alsace vous êtes monté à
bobigny sur la caisse d'allocations
familiales en criant pas l'argent pour
les étrangers il se trouve que la
procédure est encore en qui a eu 19
condamnations je crois trois mois de
sursis ou non ce n'était pas pour une
incitation à la haine raciale en
l'occurrence c'est parce que nous devons
tous
chez moi à paille à sion n'ose la mort
d'europe on est chez nous on trouvait ça
normal ça c'est pas possible
dice thaïs là vous jouez sur les mots je
suis désolé vous n'avez pas été condamné
pour ça mais vous voyez que vous êtes
hors la loi juste pas brésil justement
la loi 80 ans complète mais nous n'avons
pas été condamné le fait mouche à l'aide
à haïti
la justice a tranché nous avons été
relaxé pour notre eau notre opération
dans les alpes nous n'avons pas été
condamné pour l'occupation du chantier
la mosquée de poitiers en l'occurrence
et tous les autres motifs qui s'appelle
des nuitées dans la lèvre a conseillé
viendra vous avez le droit de le faire
oui tout à fait vincent dufour nationale
le fait est que si jamais vous obtenez
nos petites les solutions vous n'avez
pas les outils juridiques pour le faire
si on s'en tient ce week-end à l'avocat
à côté de boue qui ont suivi au poste
également d'un point gagnant le procès
si j'adore justement fabrice des visions
bien elle a résidé au nombre des visio
là plusieurs réalités en fait qui
s'enchevêtrent si vous vous dites ne
faut pas les baisser
moi je n'oublie pas non la gorgue
effectivement je connais pas le dossier
je me permettrai pas effectivement de
juger je connais le dossier parce qu'on
en parle c'est tout mais il ya deux
points soulevés ce que vous avez lu là
c'est problématique ça compte d'abord
c'est pragmatique sur le plan social
c'est dire que je crois qu'aujourd'hui
ça c'est mon sentiment personnel je
m'exprime titre personnel c'est
suffisamment compliqué la période
convient pour qu'on mette un tout petit
peu de pacification dans tout ça ça et
qu'on essaye effectivement dans une
société qui s'opposaient qui se divisent
qu'on essaye de temps en temps d'avoir
des points de convergence a dit lataif
mais moi je ne sais point de vue enfin
je suis d'accord et à dire que y'a un
prélat avait dit lataif non mais je
baille taille cinq ans ses premiers
points le deuxième prime néanmoins
néanmoins si vous voulez il faut
toujours faire attention à respecter
dans le cadre du droit et en fait si
vous voulez moi ce qui me tout ce qui me
perturbe un peu c'est ce que vous avez
lu là la question que je me pose c'est
si ces écrits sont problématiques
existait déjà
la question que je peux raisonnablement
poser c'est pourquoi cette dissolution
pas été entamée ça c'est vraiment moi je
sais c'est une question alors il ya six
mois je réponds moi je pense thaïs avec
toute l'estimé que j'ai pour vous que
j'espère réciproque qui en fait votre
ennemi c'était votre diffusion dans
cette émission
ce qu'objectivement moi ça fait
longtemps que vous suit de par mes
combats et que je vois déjà les
ratonnades médiatique et numérique que
vous faites sur les réseaux sociaux vous
avez une plate forme qui vous supportent
qui s'appelle twitter
ou quand vous chassez des gens n'y a
qu'à voir ce qui s'est passé une semaine
avec le maire de trappes qui aujourd'hui
par vos collaborateurs et quand même
menacé de mort
je me suis lassé vous il ya six mois
quand je passe ici là je sais que
pendant une semaine
pour aller au bout juste pour aller au
bout l'assise est quelque chose je pense
que quand on a fait cette émission les
gens ont découvert de manière même
stream parce que c'est le cas de cette
émission ce que vous faisiez mais je
pense qu'il ya un côté icare dans votre
association pouvait pas dire devant des
gens notamment un avocat pas vu pas vu
pas pris maintenant vous a vu on vous
prend vous parlez du ccf et de barak a
city je pense que moi j'étais totalement
contre la dissolution de ces
associations parce que comme vous le
dites de manière juridique il avait rien
d'illégal
c'est votre sentiment de croire qu'ils
sont allés avec des actions terroristes
par contre vous ce que vous faites c'est
chasser des immigrés sur le col de
montagne où aller au dessus de la mairie
de de la caf de bobigny et dire faut
virer les étrangers après de dire oui
mais le jugement est en cours c'est vrai
mais là où je rejoins l'avocat à côté de
vous qui vous dit quelque chose qui a le
c'est plausible
je veux dire que la séquence est
tellement redoutable aujourd'hui que
même quand on veut pas parler de vos
petits exploits on est obligé et
vraiment je vous dis la vérité
aujourd'hui le merde le maire de trappes
qui est menacée il ya plein de problèmes
à trappes
il ya plein de soucis c'est pas le
premier des livres où était écrit non
mais je dois aller au bout la met juste
pour aller au boulot et le et vous dire
des choses des fois qu'ils sont des
faits qui nous que vous amenez sur des
plateaux et qu'après on fait la vierge
effarouchée en dix ans mais pas du tout
moi j'ai eu votre le patron de votre de
la génération d'auditeurs qui m'envoient
tout je suis plus sur twitter j'ai été
viré c'est quand même santé vie réussie
à 10 qui dit qui disent il m'avait eu en
face de lui parler mais pas comme ça
mais je rejoins la phrase de cyril un
déjà vous fait peur à qui et 2 vous vous
prenez pour qui
parce que si aujourd'hui vous voulez
mettre une armure comme au moyen-age
avoir un glaive et décapité les
sarrasins vous faut aussi le faire
après je vous cache pas que c'est
difficile de monter dans le métro avec
une armure mais il faut justement
redescendre il ya des lois il ya une
justice on essaye de reconsolider les
liens aussi avec une police avec qui on
a pu avoir des désaccords mais tous les
policiers sont pas si on essaye de
construire mais vous vous accueillent
pour détruire et vous voulez quelque
chose et anaïs dites le moi dans les
yeux ce que vous fantasmez c'est non pas
de sortir à cannes arabe ou un noir mais
vous fantasmez l'idée d'une guerre
civile avec dakota et les musulmans et
de l'autre côté vous comme les gardiens
de la patrie mais ça je vous le dis pour
faire une guerre faut être deux non vous
aurez parvient plus à gérer mais alors
vous attendez sur les quotas ils se
répondent ici là il est soliste je suis
quand même toujours assez mal à l'aise
avec le fait que vous puissiez me faire
la leçon mais son moral
alors que je sais que vous avez quand
même été interpellés nombreux soit vous
avez sûrement vous avez été inculpée
pour harcèlement moral de nombreuses
repas non mais nous avons fait une
entrée pas là dedans pendant les deux à
l'étoile sempot judiciaire
nous n'avons pas été condamnée non mais
effectivement sous ça un petit peu
culotté ne votent pas mais non mais vous
êtes vous allez quand même pas meilleur
que moi aujourd'hui et quand ça mais
vous allez quand même pas comment
l'aider à faire non mais excusez moi là
je vous réponds ne prenez pas vraiment
pour acquis les fiches des gens qui sont
derrière vous puisque je vous le dis moi
je peut vous poursuivre si vous dit
quelque chose qui n'est pas vrai là je
suis en face de vous restez sur le sujet
de savoir à partir de quel moment vous
pensez que faire des ratonnades dans ce
pays est autorisé par génération
identitaire c'est ça ma question mais
que là vous dis depuis deux semaines
darmanin maintenant aujourd'hui de
vérifier le tir moi je n'aime pas
darmana je vous dise droit dans les yeux
je le trouve islamophobe
je trouve même que c'était une séquence
incroyable de voir marine le pen lui
dire que le problème c'est pas l'islam
c'est l'islamisme
par contre ce qu'il fait avec vous vous
avez raison c'est un enjeu politique
à partir du moment où ils tapent sur
certaines associations il doit réguler
avec vous donc maintenant selon certains
c'est balle au centre
je trouve que c'est une mauvaise idée je
rejoins certaines personnes là qui
disent non je trouve que 10 août n'est
pas une bonne idée mais le gouvernement
s'est mis tout seul dans cette impasse
la alors moi aujourd'hui a pas de
passe-droit autres j'aimerais qu'on
écoute monde émergent parce que là vous
avez quand même attaque et voit la
république en marche le gouvernement
jusqu'où vous avez à répondre y être
mais je réponds qu'aujourd'hui on a un
gouvernement et un ministre de
l'intérieur en l'occurrence gerald
harlin qui traite de la même façon
toutes les incitations à la haine et au
racisme et en l'occurrence génération
identitaire le site baraka style atuge
pas du tout d'accord avec vous
maintenant quoi j'ai donc je me suis
exprimé sur la dissolution de génération
en quantité at personnel j'espère
vraiment que pour aller à terme je ne
suis pas juriste mais je l'espère j'ai
néanmoins un problème
au delà de la question de la dissolution
avec les idées que vous véhiculez madame
parce qu'aujourd'hui fin vous nous dites
depuis des mois des années maintenant
que finalement un migrant est forcément
un terroriste et vous faites c'est à mal
par la révolution
excusez moi il ya dès aujourd'hui des
musulmans en france l'immense majorité
des musulmans ils sont français comme
vous et moi que ça vous plaise ou non il
ya des migrants qui arrivent en france
et qu'on intègre et 6 intègre aussi très
bien et donc vous êtes dans l' amalgame
permanent et ça me gêne et moi quand
j'ai en face quand je vous ai en face de
vous en fait je ressens un peu deux
choses la première c'est évidemment de
la révolte je serai toujours debout face
aux idées que vous véhiculez parce
qu'elle me semble profondément nuisibles
à la république et en même temps je vais
vous dire je comprends pas comment est
ce que je peux avoir une jeune femme qui
est de la même génération que moi on est
toutes les deux enfants de la république
et pourtant vous êtes là vomir mon
discours haineux sur les plateaux télé
ça me rend je vous dis profondément
triste alors les pandas mans de la
dissolution de génération identitaire il
ya vraiment quelque chose que je
comprends pas vous avez envie de vous
engager pour la france madame et des
gens qui sont dans la précarité allait
les aider il ya plein de choses à faire
mais arrêter profané vous avez tourné
qu'un jaillit je pense que la pause la
cause est très noble quand vous voulez
sauver votre peuple
mais lisez l'animisme les françaises qui
se font harceler sexuellement dans la
rue par des hommes qui sont à majorité
de d'origine africaine et maghrébine je
l'avais dit sur le plateau adana pour
commencer je sais je sais que c'est de
le décrire cette réalité ça vous déplaît
le fait est que ça ne reste pas qu'elles
sont belles mais je vais en islam
remercier allah je vais voter non mais
nous plaît et qui parlait pas toujours
le temps des chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur lui même donc à ce moment là
on pourra pas les nier c'est à dire que
dans les transports en commun en ile de
france vous avez 93% des viols qui sont
commis par des étrangers et 60 62 a
tonné 60 ans un étranger non mais 65 me
suis battu pour cent des agressions
sexuelles commises par des étoiles et
alice qu'est-ce qu'ils font ça c'est la
soumission
assad a dit david hess qui pourrait ce
que ca génération identitaire pour
babini mais c'est ce que je dis ça donne
envie
non mais vous faire justice eux-mêmes
c'est sa génération l'identitaire 2 de
faire un groupe est de dire bah nous on
va faire
on va faire une milice nous on va
essayer les justiciers de la france mais
sud apparaît comme je vous avez vous
vous prenez pour qui
mais je suis d'accord avec vous cyril on
n'aurait pas à le faire c'est
gouvernement faisait son travail sans
toutefois tant que la belgique est la
loi et que les migrants clandestins le
travail il s'en tire sans aucun contrôle
faisant travail que gérald darmanin ne
fait pas et justement ça qui est bon et
si jamais vous n'avez pas monter une
visite sans broncher je me souviens du
cerpa humilié maison l'intérieur de
l'assemblée un petit peu surtout si nous
étions le le motif d'inculpation a
procédé à le c'était effectivement la
constitution de milices via nous avons
été relaxé donc dans sa naïveté ni vous
ne pouvez pas vous faire justice vous
même
voilà qui gardaient les idées il y avait
les idées sont à combattre mais assuré
but à la fin et moi je vous le dit les
yeux dans les yeux vos idées sont à
vomir
en revanche je trouve que la dissolution
c'est pas bien c'est pas une bonne
stratégie
parce que ça va les victimiser et vous
l'entendez et ce en train de dire le
gouvernement contre nous du coup ils se
font une sorte de virginité médiatique
madame sa cause de la décision de
monsieur d'art pour moi c'est une
mauvaise décision et ils vont se
reformer
ils se sont formés sur les bras d'une
association dissoute en 2002 sont très
malins après demain il y aura des
solutions et ils vont reformer notre
association continue et ballan c'est sur
elle et sur les idées j'en avais taipei
d'escautpont mineurs ainsi génération
identitaire voilà demain n'existe plus
vous allez reformé il est bien sûr sait
déjà c'est bien prévu jeu à ce que je
sache je pense police ou une association
ça n'empêche pas ses membres de
continuer à faire de la police
c'est une antiphrase fonctionner
parfaitement dans votre élément et en
plus vous aurez le droit de le faire
bomber région d'où venez vous souhaitez
10 ou deux générations identitaire mais
63% des français ne veulent plus
d'immigration qu'est ce que vous faites
vous dise où vous du parti politique
laissé ça c'est comme si mon nom mais
c'est comme s'il y avait de la marine
française qui va hills calif
on est content je suis sûr qu'ils m'ont
pour que vous montez pas partis
politiques là en faisant vous
affranchissez de toit toutes les étapes
électorales qui font qu'à partie moi par
exemple je combats je suis assez
d'accord ce qui a été dit moi je combat
le front national
mais ils sont légitimes en représentant
30% des français et on les combat sur
les idées moi messi par exemple ce n'est
pas quelqu'un avec une ratonnade il
descendre jusque là mais ea dont vous
dire ça mais je pense que aussi le fait
de vous dissoudre c'est que on allait
aller dans une impasse jusqu'à peut-être
un fait divers atroce mais c'est à dire
que moi je pense que des deux côtés à
une provocation et que si par exemple
vous étiez attaqués parce que vous étiez
le pardon de vous dire ça dans
l'antichambre avant de vous faire
justice a tabassé un mec comparé dont
moi je suis né en 82 je suis issue d'une
génération qui a vu malik oussékine qui
ont vu des gens mourir et qui
aujourd'hui je vous dis pas que la
gauche ne nous a pas enfermer dans un
truc anti anti raciste mielleux qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que des
cas français d'origine africaine prend
la parole c'est forcément pour dire non
on peut être de droite on peut être de
gauche on peut être d'extrême gauche
mais lorsque vous faites c'est que vous
vous donnez le droit et je comprends le
regard inquiet de cyril ou des autres
c'est de vous dire pourquoi pas tabasser
des gens et vous dire de toute manière
la police va rien faire
et puis pas qu'on n'ait pas jugé ont le
droit de le faire non non mais pardon je
suis désolé mais lorsqu'il va vous
laisser dire ça c'est à dire que on n'a
jamais été un coup on n'a jamais fait
pas prier ce que vous avez encore nous
n'avons jamais cédé
je pense que si ça s'était produit à la
justice ce serait tranchée en revanche
nous avons fait condamner des personnes
qui avaient des propos diffamatoires à
notre encontre
donc je vous le dis faites attention à
ce que vous alors que ça c'est du malus
des ce que font tes défauts il ya ça
fait deux fois que vous venez sur le
plateau sur btp et dans tpm pc très bien
devenir
ça fait deux fois que vous nous citer
des chiffres je sais pas vous dans la
sortie non mais s'il n'existe pas
interdit donc que ça sente pas
d'incidence regarde je vous ai pas
assisté décès adam technique je vous
hais cette session étrangers si c'était
des étrangers bien n'a pas de
statistiques n'existent pas il ya des
statistiques de nationalité on est
d'accord permet à danané man records en
commun quelques portes
il n'était pas dit que les statistiques
c'était autant de personnages étaient
d'origine africaine ou maghrébine ont
ils étaient à l'étranger
j'avais des suédois a réservé sa
nationalité non mais juste la taille
c'est vrai vous jouez sur les mots je
vous le dis et vote et ça prouve bien
que votre chiffre et evo scientifiques
veulent rien dire maintenant au
lancement ouais mais ministère de
l'intérieur n'y a pas de statistiques
vous avez le droit de dire oui mais ça
n'a rien à voir
vous avez le droit en fait de trouver
que il ya trop d'étrangers en france
qu'il ya trop d'immigration
marine le pen le dit elle a le droit de
le dire moi je vous rejoins encore une
fois pas du tout sur vos idées je les
combats mais c'est votre liberté
en revanche les propos que vous tenez ce
que cyril vous avez lu tout à l'heure
sur notre site internet ou ce que vous
faites dans vos actions avec les
mosquées ou quand vous allez crier dans
les années dans des manifestations
l'islam hors de france on est chez nous
en fait tout ça encore une fois
s'appelle du racisme
le racisme c'est pas une opinion mais
vous jamais été condamné pour la presse
aussi et ça ils n'oublieront jamais été
jusque là en l'occurence j'ai juste le
dossier après dossier qui est monté il
est bien par rapport à ça je ne suis pas
en mesure de vous dire est ce qu'il
pourra aller au bout parce que pour une
fois je suis pas juriste mais je reste
assez convaincu que ce que vous faites
ça participe à fracturer profondément la
société et c'est extrêmement grave juste
thaïs vous les sortez d'où vos chiffres
sauf statistiques ministériels il faut
peu pour vous les amener pas mais
j'aurais pu les amener les amèneraient
vous reviendrez mais comment accès à 100
mais sortira hip hop vous dis oui
juste une chose parce que je vous
remercie pour la publicité de génération
minoritaire c'est grâce à balances ton
post tic on a beaucoup parlé mais moi
j'ai une question à vous poser même à
votre avis demain matin une faute la
dissolution et fait qu'est-ce que ça va
changer
ça va chauffer lol non mais une
organisation avec des mots
lien avec un cadre non mais le problème
change rien normal des problèmes si les
idées et leur verser ça c'est combattre
des idées les invités partout et puis un
moment donné raison à des millions de
personnes ont fait des centaines de
milliers de gens qui les écoutent qui
les suivent les qui les croient quand
vous parlez de statistique c'est quand
même très grave de donner ses
statistiques sur un plateau parce qu'il
ya des gens qui nous regardent et qui
pensent qu'il ya maintenant quatre ans
mettons de violeurs s'est donc ça c'est
à tisser que c'est n'importe quoi
non mais elle n'existe pas vous mais je
les enverrais demain voilà et vous
verrez qu'elle n'existe pas ou non
qu'est ce que ça change de mains une
fois que celle à 10 mois la structure il
ya une structure juridique sur
financiers conséquents me doutais de ces
dix listes et d'ailleurs si quelqu'un
sans restriction la ces importantes
peut-être vous dit quelque chose de
l'ordre du symbole c'est pas impossible
alors moi m'attaquer à un symbole comme
un malheur ça me dérange pas du tout ça
avant par libourne avait des choses très
bien énoncé a effectivement il faut
aller je suis d'accord avec vous sur le
terrain des idées c'est aussi pour ça
que je suis là ce soir
la série avait jugé watan j'espère que
génération identitaire pourra forcément
être dissous je connais pas la vente de
gré à gré c'est aussi d'exprimer en quoi
ce que vous véhiculez c'est le pur loin
jugeant la pelouse effectivement au
génial et sur le plan des idées justice
pour comment comment il ya plein de gens
qui rallie comment on peut rejeter une
personne dans votre groupuscule au seul
motif qu'elle a câliné enveloppe
différente de la vôtre
voilà c'est à dire voilà que vous c'est
ça en fait l'oeuvre peut pas s'inscrire
non mais ça non mais pourquoi c'est quoi
votre problème vous n'avez pas compris
le discours mba sont passés de la
caricature parce que non parce que je
peux m'offrir un nom la lune non mais
écoutez on était encore
nous prêtons émission il ya des gens des
gens arabes noirs qui ont essayé pour la
blague de s'inscrire
juste pour essayer et en fait il se
donne un droit de regard selon ton
identité c'est à dire que c'est une
boîte de nuit raciste mais pardon de
dire quelque chose qui est fait au clair
c'est à dire que moi ce que je comprends
pas c'est que vous vous disiez je suis
assez d'accord ce qui a été dit c'est
pour ça qu'on est partagé moi je pense
qu objectivement le gouvernement s'est
mis dans une impasse et comme je le dit
à leur devais dissoute de choses mais la
réalité c'est que quand c'est arrivé ici
je thaïs objectivement vous reconnaît
dans la rue c'est à double tranchant
vous avez fait parler de votre
association mais par contre vous étiez
visible et moi je vais parler au nom des
musulmans si je puis me permettre
vous savez depuis qu'on sait que vous
allez dissous il ya six millions et demi
de musulmans n'y a pas six millions et
demi terroristes on est d'accord au
moins sur ces chiffres là peut-être
ressenti vous avez l'impression qui en a
cinq millions mais je voudrais smic est
quelque chose
la réalité c'est qu'en fait depuis que
c'est arrivé depuis que c'est arrivé
ce que je vois depuis que c'est arrivé
depuis que les gens ont appris que vous
étiez nous allait être dissous il ya un
espèce de truc envers l'état même pas le
gouvernement puisque le gouvernement se
trouve dans un an ils vont être heurtés
par d'autres gens tout aussi compétent
incompétent jugera mais la réalité c'est
qu'on se dit hein
enfin ils font quelque chose que le mou
le musulman est en danger en france
parce qu'aujourd'hui dans la communauté
musulmane
quand vous arracher le voile d'une femme
voilée dans une gare et vous dites vous
retrouverez pas entre eux ils ont la
pression une fois pas de propos
diffamatoires mettant ses mensonges et à
vous monter sur le toit d'une mosquée
est ce que c'est pour faire dans le foot
en salle ou juste parce que vous sentez
en puissance les dates les héritiers de
charles c'était un champ mais ces
mosquées donc ce n'est pas une banderole
et nous demandions un référendum sur
l'immigration
juste après il exagère questions à poser
à taille juste fabrice des vidéos en
fait tout le monde se trompe dans ce
débat a bondi de débats et de débats et
en foot ou trop contraignants sont
défoncées il ya le débat effectivement
du juridique de la structure associative
oui il ya le débat effectivement des
idées dans maintenant reste sur les cds
vous trompez c'est qu'effectivement les
idées vous pouvez pas les combattre ce
droit vous pouvez combat par leur part
les limites de la loi pénale
mais jean mais seulement et que en fait
si l'objectif de dissoudre une
association c'est finalement de
combattre des idées vous vous trompez de
cadres voulait renforcer un tromper
cadre des idées ça se combat pied à pied
pas sûr
mais attendez mais le racisme c'est pas
une idée mais je dire en l'occurrence
effectivement vous vous trompez pas ce
que vous venez parler de racisme
moi je connais pas les motifs qui
préside à la dissolution de son identité
et vous non plus en fait donc vous
parler de quelque chose que vous
connaissez pas vous pouvez parler des
idées mais vous pouvez pas parler des
motifs qui préside à la dissolution
parce que ces motifs qui sont juridiques
ils sont pas politiques ça se fabrique
des vidéos moi j'aimerais et que poser
une question à taez thaïs sa houppette
vraiment que génération identitaire soit
dissous ça vous pèse vraiment bien vous
vous dites on va faire autre chose on
s'en fout ta façon c'est un coup dur
parce que danser dans un sens il attaque
la première ligne d'attaqué comme j'ai
pu dire l'organisation qui était la plus
efficace
néanmoins ce n'est pas pour autant que
nous sommes moins déterminés à combattre
l'immigration massive qui elle pour le
coup est un réel danger pour les
français je veux dire vous parler d'
islamophobie l'islamophobie en france
c'est zéro mort en revanche depuis les
attentats de charlie hebdo c'est plus de
260 morts françaises tué par l'êta nous
avait déjà donné vous me comparer unités
mobiles en baisse mais même s'il
n'existe pas c'est parce qu'on perd on
combine des morts des vraiment preuve de
cette fois-ci terrorisme c est madame
attention leur sésame noir on doit
rendre l'antenne gilbert la question à
vous poser pourquoi un
voilà un arabe un juif anwar vaudrait
mieux que vous aurez droit bien que vous
voudrez bien que vous non mais c'est
ridicule comme ici parce que quand je
lis vos espoirs est-ce que j'ai quand
même le droit de demander à ce que les
miens passe avant les autres dans mon
pays
ce qu'on demande c'est que la loi sera
appliquée à l'égard des migrants que
l'on n'essaie pas parce qu'on est blond
aux yeux bleus et des français je viens
ça le sujet media center pour bouger
mujahid je vous le dis vraiment moi je
suis pas sur le truc à les jeunes et
tous je me dis qu'il ya vingt ans vous
êtes là j'aimerais pas vous croisez à 40
mais je vous dis objectivement si pour
vous être français issus de
l'immigration s'est marqué au stade de
france d'une tête contre le brésil
je ne serai jamais français à vos yeux
je suis français et objectivement comme
disaient les béruriers noirs
j'emmerde le front national comme ça ça
alors après après voilà après comme jean
nous ici voilà nous les électeurs du
rassemblement national ouakid regarde et
on a volé il ya tous les cas tous les
bords politiques qui nous regardent
après on peut pas se mettre à la place
des électeurs
il ya des gens qui souffrent qui ont des
vies qui sont pas les nôtres ont des
liens privilégiés
oui on va pas se mentir il ya des gens
qui ont voté à droite ya des gens qui
ont voté à gauche et des gens que vous
êtes au milieu et je le dis souvent ils
sont toujours dans la même merde
aucun moment on ne peut pas se mettre à
leur place et on peut pas donner des
leçons moi je dirais jamais voté ou pour
qui ne pas voter parce que voilà je vous
le dis nous on est des privilégiés et il
faut se mettre à la place de gens qui
ont beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés et
qui s'en sortent pas mal d années et des
années qui ont voté pour tous les partis
et qui sont toujours à la même merde et
un moment ils disent eh bah écoutez nous
eh ben on va sanctionner aussi les
partis qui ont été lavés venu entorse et
occident peut pas se mettre à leur place
donc chacun fait ce qu'il veut
maintenant vous vous êtes un groupuscule
moi je le pense que la meilleure phrase
le soir c'est yassine belattar caddie
monter votre parti politique parce que
là vous outrepassez vos droits et vous
voilà c'est sympa c'est comme la
représenter aux élections alors c'est
tout et là vous serez plus heureux
voilà ma jun vous n'allez pas demander
ça des associations et ong le mode
d'action nous opérons d'action que nous
avons
regardez regardez non à 66 consciente
oui non à 66% pour diverses raisons
voilà ce qui montre bien qu
effectivement il y a quand même il ya
quand même une énorme partie des deux
tiers des françaises et français qui est
beaucoup de gens notre combat non